hello freak [ __ ] they're sort of
responsible for putting out you know an
infinite number of forest fires all
around them all the time social economic
you know dealing with different cultures
it's not doesn't seem like it'd be an
easy gig yeah and in one of the words
that they have now too is you know even
though they have a large market share
for search they see search is sort of a
gateway to the world mm-hmm and they
don't necessarily have a huge market
share for that because you know Facebook
and Twitter are also ways to get to the
world's information and a lot of
Facebook just it's just a walled garden
where Google can't really get into that
so some people just and you know on your
phone you spend most of your time on
Facebook or something and not
necessarily just doing random google
searches you know yeah I got off of that
I don't really go on Facebook for that
very reason it seems to be to be the
biggest sucker of time that we have I
just I feel like Twitter to me is like
it's limited by 140 characters it seems
like pretty straightforward I get links
get interesting stories get sent to me
that for my needs that's more it's more
appealing and then Instagram is very
appealing because I like images you look
at pictures and sometimes people write
cool captions and find out about
interesting [ __ ] but Facebook is like
woo boy you're gonna lose a lot of time
on that [ __ ] yeah that so this
is a Reno tangent but I knew it so I
worked on image search and they also see
that even though there isn't a huge
competitor for image search there's
Instagram and Pinterest which are very
similar things and you know we do our
demographic research and we really look
into why people are using these products
and we see it that the majority of the
users are women and you know they
actually know why that is it's that
women prefer you know art and aesthetics
over men and on average right and that's
exactly what I had in the document like
I really when he open like now
we're looking at the products because
otherwise you know you're not gonna give
these random ads to people that you know
if you know that they're a man and
you're not gonna give them ads for women
products you know right so Adsense does
discriminate and stereotype people in
some ways but but it's okay although now
they're getting into trying to D by us
machine learning so if they do see any
things that the machine learning has
learned these statistical anomalies are
just trends in the data then they'll try
to remove that why that seems it would
be less effective it's less effective
but they see it as a scrimmage social
justice yeah it's I don't mess what a
mess
Bing you need to step up your game come
on Ben bring back that Windows Phone
[Laughter]
nobody uses hotmail does that even real
anymore I I think so I so I've been
getting a lot of emails from you know
pretty paranoid people and some of them
are from hot now so oh yeah yeah well I
got a PA well comment what the [ __ ] AOL
is real where are you right now like
we're worried what do you do with your
time yeah I read books respond to media
requests eat a lot of them yeah I still
get a lot and you know thankfully now
some of them are more of the long form
which I allot I like a lot more than
just the five minute TV thing yeah I
wanted to give you as much time as he
could to just yeah talk about this and
especially after I heard you on bench P
Rochelle show I'm like this guy's
getting the shaft you're a reasonable
person you're not a misogynist at all as
far as I can tell you don't seem like a
sexist you don't seem cruel you're not
like the type of person I think we go
out of their way to promote some sort of
a quote unquote harmful stereotypes
ender stereotype just seems so weird
especially like I personal
just very conscious about a lot of these
gender stereotypes and you know I use
the word day whenever the whenever the
gender of someone is unknown or just
unimportant mm-hmm and like I try to
avoid using guys instead of just like
you all or something yeah I say folks I
try to say folks now because I used to
say guys a lot you know I try to use to
term folks yeah but yeah for that very
reason yeah
[Applause]
[Music]